hey up guys my name is CH welcome to the
code review series a series in which I
take a look at the code that you send me
over the last few episodes we have been
looking at a 2d game engine that took
the author 2,000 hours to make we have
uncovered some problems with it that I
have talked about over these last few
videos and it even led to me making a
video about how to properly set up C++
projects which you can find up there I
think we are coming to a close with this
project in fact I was actually going to
choose a new project for this episode
but then I realized there's actually
like there is quite a lot of code here
in in fact let's start by actually
seeing how much code there is here so
over here in the source directory let's
just run this clock program to measure
the lines of code 242 files and 48,000
lines of code so that's that's quite a
bit of code and specifically just having
a browse through all of this because
like yeah there's quite a lot of stuff
to be discovered here that's why like I
mean people have been saying that 2,000
hours like this doesn't look like a
project that has had 2,000 hours of work
poured into it because the stuff that
we've looked at you know has not been
the the the best code and the best
design but the thing is the amount of
time that you work on a project has
nothing to do with the quality of that
project and the level I guess of quality
of that project an experienced
programmer who knows exactly how to
build a 2d game engine might take a few
hundred hours and build something far
superior to this but then someone who's
just a beginner and just learning all
about game engines can just enjoy the
process of building this game engine and
if they work on it for you know in this
case over 2,000 hours like you are
physically going to end up with a large
program a large project a lot of code
but if you spend all of your time just
programming and not learning then the
product you make is probably not going
to be very good even though it is
physically large and it might have a lot
of features which is what we're seeing
here now this might sound discouraging
but I I don't want this to be
discouraging because this actually
reminds me of something that I used to
do back in the day I don't know if you
asked for a story but you're getting a
story right now so when I first started
programming I distinctly remember that
in year 12 the this is the final year of
high school here in Australia I was
sitting in my English class with my
laptop and to have a bit of fun I
thought that I would basically work on a
game now this point in my life I had
probably around a year worth of
programming experience I only knew Java
and I really only knew how to make games
from scratch kind of in Java so over the
course of the semester when I had a
little bit of spare time in that English
class me and my friend who was sitting
next to me we would kind of work on this
game he didn't know any programming so
I'd be writing all the code but together
we would be coming up with like you know
what features I should add and because I
had this friend sitting next to me I
made a game that we could both play like
on one computer just on one keyboard and
it was a game called Squad which I
actually ended up remaking later for a
game Jam but the game is basically there
are two squares one of them has to tag
the other ones who just Chase each other
around like a fixed screen and so
because this was just really about
having a bit of fun playing this game
and being able to program in new
features I didn't really spend much time
researching anything other than probably
like Java API things whatever feature we
would come up with I would just try try
and find a solution for it on the spot
Without Really Trying to like learn the
proper way to do it and the code was
really really bad I mean maybe maybe we
could code review that for fun one day
young Cho code is always terrible but
anyway the point of this story is that
even though the code did not turn out
very good and I would completely write
it in a different way even a year after
that because I learned so much more
stuff it was still I think a very
valuable experience for me to sit down
and actually use my brain to try and
work out Solutions to problems without
knowing that what I was doing was
objectively terrible because what it did
is it made me think and then later I was
able to see why those Solutions were not
very good and why there are certain
better Solutions because I could
experience that firsthand instead of
just being told don't do that that's bad
for whatever reason do do it this way
instead however if you're going to spend
2,000 hours on writing a 2d game engine
I would definitely recommend that you
balance that with learning and education
which basically means pick up a book for
example game engine architecture by
Jason Gregory that's a really good one
look at some existing projects on GitHub
to see how they structure things read
some articles to see what a potential
good way to structure an entity
component system might be this project
specifically is using sfml so maybe look
at some example sfml games or
documentation to see what a good way to
use that Library would be or if you're
at the beginning of your programming
Journey then why not check out
brilliant.org the sponsor of this video
for free brilliant.org is an amazing
website filled with lots and lots of
really high quality courses on various
stem topics it's an excellent way to
dive into programming for the first time
because they have some really good
beginner level computer science courses
that will help you think like a
programmer and because I believe the
programming and math are really really
important together brilliant is an
amazing choice because they also have a
lot of really good math courses now why
brilliant specifically because their
courses are super engaging and
interactive they have these widgets you
can play with to see how things work
like for example in their calculus
course calculus can be pretty hard but
being able to visually see how numbers
change things can be really really
helpful and did I mention that you'll
also get quizzed to make sure that
you're learning and retaining this
information now of calculus is to
advance for you don't worry because
brilliant mouth courses go all the way
down to their everyday mouth course
which is a fantastic gentle introduction
into the world of mouth and you can get
started for free they have a 30-day free
trial that you can use to check out all
of the courses on their platform and see
if you like them and if you do brilliant
have been nice enough to offer the first
200 subscribers 20% off an annual
membership huge thank you to
brilliant.org as always for sponsoring
this video so yeah if you're going to
invest a lot of time into a project
don't forget to also invest time in
education and learning so today I wanted
to take a look at the entity component
system uh because there seems to be some
sort of entity component system inside
this engine I don't think it's exactly
set up you know to be an actual entity
component system that might sound
confusing what I mean is that just
because you have a class called
component and you have entities does not
mean you've created an entity component
system an ECA an entity component system
system or an ECS for short is a specific
type of kind of data structure and
system and the benefit of an ECS or at
least the two kind of major major
features that I think are important for
it to be an ECS are the compositional
functionality meaning you can create an
entity and then compose its
functionality by just adding in whatever
components you want arbitrarily and they
all just work together but then also the
performance because what you're doing is
you're batching together operations that
are required to happen for components
and you're storing components usually
continuously in memory so that even
though we visually see different
entities doing different things when it
comes to the computer processing those
entities it doesn't worry about them
being actual entities and then having to
Traverse whatever components they have
it specifically bulk batch kind of
processes the components all in a row
together which is what makes it so fast
so that's basically my checklist when
I'm looking at whether or not this is a
correct implementation of an entity
component system now isn't ECS the
absolute best solution for all cases no
there there is no best solution for all
cases there are definitely things that
are better in probably 99% of cases
which is why we consider them to be
superior solutions to certain problems
in computer science but to be honest
like computers are so complicated and
just requirements are so different like
your requirement might be so simple that
any solution fits the bill and some
solutions might be easier to extend or
easier to understand for more Junior
developers which might make them the
Superior Solution even though they might
perform 10% worse because 10% of a few
micros seconds might not be significant
all right anyway so we have this class
called component this is like our Base
Class we have a couple virtual functions
so immediately this tells me that of
course this is going to be derived from
yeah so I mean to me this like already
shows a little bit of a problematic
behavior for an ECS because if you have
derived classes you can't exactly store
them as components and still have
contiguous memory that's usually not
what you you would do anyway with
different components usually what we do
is we have buckets so you might have
like a Sprite component you might have a
transform component and then the idea is
within those buckets we allocate memory
and we just store these components all
in a row and that way like let's just
say we have a transform component and
it's a 4x4 Matrix that might be 64 bytes
of memory right so if you have 64 bytes
of memory one after the other and they
are really truly contiguous the benefit
there is that if I need to access all of
these because I'm iterating through all
the transform components in my scene
because I want to do some rendering or
whatnot this this obviously gets a
little bit more complicated because if
you're going to do rendering you also
need Sprite components does the entity
have a Sprite component maybe it's an
audio thing it has a transform but not a
Sprite component anyway of course this
gets more complicated but I'm just
trying to keep things simple here if we
have all of these then when we ask for
this first one our CPU will prefetch a
bunch of memory that's going to be more
hot on our CPU cache and it means that
it's it's kind of like we don't have to
request the memory for each transform
component we kind of batch it together
it's like if you were shipping something
from one country to another it's all
coming from the same warehouse and in
fact the boxes are next to each other
they can just package that into let's
just say one big box ship it to you get
everything all at once it's obviously
much more efficient than if they're
coming from three different warehouses
and you have to send them all
independently that's basically what
you're doing when you're creating
contiguous memory that you can fetch all
at once instead of having it all be
segregated in different parts of your
physical RAM now if you have
components and they're virtual classes
basically so you have this Base Class
called component and then you have all
of these derived classes that you create
for sprite component transform component
You Know audio component whatever you
might have then obviously the only way
that you can store them in a contigous
block of memory is by creating pointers
out of them and so you have a pointer to
an instance of a derived class which
then of course will live in heat memory
somewhere in a arbitrary location that
will not be contiguous now some more
more words here just to dive a little
bit deeper into this I said Heap
allocation here because I mean I've seen
in this project I don't think there are
custom allocators I think this person is
just using the new keyword and it's not
like overridden with a custom allocator
or anything they're just using the
standard stock standard C++ new keyword
to allocate memory in which case it will
come from an arbitrary place if they
were using a custom allocator in an
arena technically maybe this memory
might be a bit more together and a bit
more contiguous but we're not going to
talk about that the other possibility is
that you don't technically have to Heap
allocate derived classes you can just
stack allocate them now the reason why
that's uncommon is for a couple of
reasons but the main reason in this case
would be they'd all be different sizes
so this transform component might be 64
bytes plus you know these one bite Bings
so you might have 66 bytes but then
because they are viral functions that
also be a v table so you have that size
but then a Sprite component might have
different members therefore it will be a
completely different size so because
these aren't all the same size you'd
need to store the size for each of these
which can be done I mean this is C++
this is programming we could do whatever
we want we could have a table of
integers or of you know U 64 Ts that
were sizes or really offsets of each
component within this list there's
probably a little bit confusing but at
that point what you're doing is instead
of this just being like a traditional
Vector of memory where you have like
each element is a fixed size they're all
uniformly sized you're kind of turning
it into just a buffer of contiguous
memory and then your seral in it
basically and then you have different
offsets for different elements anyway I
don't know why sometimes I just get
carried away so pulling out of the depth
now and going back to my simple
explanation in the beginning that's why
having like a polymorphic you know
derived class like a this hierarchy of
classes for component generally not a
good idea and why traditional anti
component systems probably I mean not
that I've you know read all of them but
in my experience they would usually just
not not do that and as an example if we
take a look at Hazel and its components
you can see that they're just like
struct mesh component that's it struct
animation component that's it it's not
derived from anywhere it's just an
independent struct of data that's that's
all it is so taking a look at an example
I mean it looks like we have yeah so we
have like this transform component and
it's derived from component I don't know
why you have these name spaces
everywhere if this is inside that name
space but we'll ignore that so the
transform has a scale a rotation a unu
32 rotation I'm assuming that's probably
degrees but then you're also storing
that as a as an integer interesting
choice um these so these are private
members then we have public which
position text deid next position last
position position parent this is a lot
of stuff for a transform component now
what I'm interested in at this stage um
is just basically how so there's there's
an init function and then inside the
init function we reset it which will I
mean here's a Constructor the
Constructor will do a bunch of stuff but
then reset will also just yeah set all
of these things and attach Sprite and
it's a Sprite pointer wow so wow so so
transforms have a Sprite pointer in them
so Sprite in this engine is kind of like
entity because there is no entity and
because this is called Sprite engine and
it's the 2D engine the Sprites are the
entities and I don't know if that
extends to entities that don't get
rendered so for example like an audio
listener or some kind of physics
bounding box that might not have a
visual rendered representation whether
or not that's also considered a Sprite
or not but as far as I'm aware Sprite is
the same as entity in this in this
engine so it's got a reference to that
which is a little bit weird that's not
something that you would typically do
what I am interested in though is where
does this live let's see if we can
find where there's a lot of transform
stuff here let's find maybe like is this
a component yes let's just try and find
this cuz transform is such a common
thing maybe this is less common okay
this animated okay Sprite so there's
Sprite . CPP and sprite. and so this is
the Sprite class so this is kind of like
the entity class and we've got an ID
we've got a parent ID we've got a which
is the SFL Sprite okay oh and then we've
got all the components here a stack
allocated oh man oh oh boy oh and then
we've also got what we've also got this
pointer to all the child so we've got
all the children as points here as well
as the parents but then remember how in
a previous episode we also looked at
Sprite repository which also has a
collection of Sprites and then yeah it's
got a vector of Sprites which is really
I think that's root level Sprite because
then we've got all of the all of the
children and it's stored inside a tree
which is why for example this get old
child or get all children function will
be recursive because it will keep having
to Traverse the tree since the ones Tor
inside Sprite repository are just the
high level ones and that is why again we
have we have to have a Vector of all of
the children here because the one in
Sprite repository is just the root level
nodes but these are all of the the local
relations or related Sprites I guess I
have talked about why this is not great
and you don't want to have a tree and
you want to have a flat list instead and
if you did have a flat list I would also
not have you wouldn't have this
hierarchy built inside of each Sprite
because then what you're doing is you're
kind of duplicating your data across
you're you should have a central place
where you just stored the hierarchy and
that's it and Sprite shouldn't be aware
of its hierarchy if it needs to be it
asks whatever is storing the hierarchy
what are my children instead of
containing a copy basically of that
children list itself because that's
super annoying to maintain if that makes
sense like you have to not only not only
tell the data storage that stuff has
changed but then also tell each
individual Sprite that their hierarchy
has been updated and that just gets
messy and it's also very bug prone but
this I'm upset about this I don't think
there's a lot of there's a lot of things
to say here this is definitely not uh
any kind kind of ECS any kind of antic
component system at least not the
traditional definition of what that is
the first problem with this really is a
design kind of architecture problem and
that is the fact that a Sprite
automatically has these components and
also you're storing them inside the
Sprite generally not what you want to do
because now if I want to for example
render all of the Sprites in my scene
what I have to do is I can't just get
all of the like Sprite renderer
components and the transform components
and whatever else I might need to render
it and just kind of iterate through all
of the ones that I have inside my seen
and rendered them I have to actually
visit every Sprite and then ask it hey
do you have a Sprite renderer yes okay I
need to use that Sprite render component
now that's not good because now I'm
iterating through all the Sprites and
all of the data that's associated with
it so if I fetch a Sprite for example
here's what I'm trying to say if I fetch
a Sprite for example I'm automatically
fetching all of this data like there's a
lot of stuff here that I'm automatically
receiving but I don't need half of it
and that's the benefit of the ECS the
fact that I'm going to get tunnel vision
I'm going to close my eyes and I'm only
going to care about just this system
just what it needs so this the rendering
needs the Sprite render component the
transform whatever else I'm just going
to focus on that because if I do that
it's just going to run faster but with
this it's like you focus on the whole
Sprite because that's what you're doing
and then you have to fetch all of this
stuff that you don't care about physics
is not related to rendering so why would
I care about that but yet I have to
because the Sprite renderer is nestled
in between all of these other systems
that I care about and that's really not
good for design that's why you would
batch all of that data together and
store different components in different
buckets you can also inter leave
components if you want with other ones
but that's besides the point that's not
what's happening here anyway the other
thing is all of them are automatically
added so an animator like this Sprite
might not have an animation but it
obviously has an animator component in
some fashion and then also these are not
Heap allocated these are stack allocated
that's not the biggest problem here uh
it you have to be careful with that
because if you do have derived class
classes that are stack allocated then if
you do pass this into a function for
example that takes just components you
might think that would work because
you're downcasting it basically into its
base class but if it's stack allocated
that's going to result in object slicing
because when you do this there's no
information stored that basically tells
it that no no no I actually am a Sprite
render component it just casts you down
to a component which as we know only has
two bullings and that's it and then you
kind of you basically can't recover that
data that you have inside transform so
all of this would basically be cut off
and lost and sliced off so that's called
object slicing and I recommend that you
look that up as well if you want more
information so for that reason I I
probably wouldn't do that it's not it's
not that you can't do that it's just
that you you want to you just need to be
careful with that that's all but even if
we ignore the performance problems of
putting all of these into Sprite and
then having to visit each Sprite to then
get its components and send them to like
a system there's some systems here we
can look at as well well maybe next time
but ignoring the performance things I
also just don't like the fact that
they're all always present you know like
they're all here when you create a
Sprite you automatically construct all
of these objects it kind of ruins the
the compositional attribute that I
mentioned like the fact that you can
compose this with whatever you like
they're all already here uh which I
don't like but anyway I hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you did please
don't forget to hit the like button
leave your thoughts as well in the
comment section below should I keep
looking at this should I try and present
some possible solutions to these
problems let me know as well in the
comments section below don't forget to
check out brilliant.org and I will see
you guys next time goodbye